an urgent warning about the coronavirus
and new questions about the White House
response dr. Anthony Fauci told Congress
yesterday the coronavirus is not going
to disappear he said the next few weeks
will be critical as cases surge across
the country but at a rally in Arizona
President Trump once again claimed the
virus is going away that was exactly
that kind of event that experts are
warning Americans to avoid it's a large
indoor gathering where a few people are
wearing masks which are Jang as a story
from the White House thousands of young
people packed into a Phoenix Church to
see President Trump who ignored the
mayor's plea to follow city orders and
set an example to residents by wearing a
mask and once again the president
described the virus with the racist slur
kung fu' speaking in Arizona which hit a
record high of over 3,500 reported new
covin 19 cases on Tuesday mr. Trump
claimed the nation had turned a corner
we're doing so well after the plague
it's going away but testifying on
Capitol Hill earlier dr. Anthony Fauci
said it wasn't that simple in some
respects we've done very well however in
other areas of the country we're now
seeing a disturbing surge of infections
that looks like it's a combination but
one of the things is an increase in
community spread and that's something
that I'm really quite concerned about
and president Trump's event was the
opposite of what dr. pouchy recommended
plan a don't go in a crowd Plan B if you
do make sure you wear a mask meanwhile
Falchi and other health officials said
the president has never asked them to
slow down testing it's the opposite
we're gonna be doing more testing not
less despite what mr. Trump said on
Saturday
White House officials insisted he was
just joking we asked the president
himself we have got the greatest testing
program anywhere in the world testing is
a double-edged sword in one way it tells
you you have cases in another way you
find out where the cases are press
secretary Kiwi mackaninee later said
President Trump was using sarcasm to
make a serious point today the president
will host his polish counterpart here at
the White House the first world leader
to visit since the pandemic began all
members of both delegations will be
tested for the virus Anthony we just
thank you